wenn in der corona-krise alle
Ausstellungen eines Künstlers abgesagt
werden und seine Karriere am seidenen
Faden hängt was macht er da am besten
okay liegt jetzt nicht unbedingt auf der
Hand aber für unseren ganz speziellen
Fall gilt genau das er tut etwas Gutes
der spreer-sprung aus Gelsenkirchen hat
genau das gemacht und er hat wieder
einen Sinn in seiner Arbeit gefunden das
Besondere an diesem Video ihr könnt eins
seiner Bilder bekommen los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen schon die Begegnung
mit Sprung findet an einem mysteriösen
Ort statt in einer Pyramide mitten auf
einem Schulgelände in Gelsenkirchen hier
an der evangelischen Gesamtschule
Gelsenkirchen arbeitet der Künstler und
er gibt sein Wissen weiter also das ist
meine ehemalige Schule und ich bin
ehrenamtlicher Zeichenlehrer in dieser
Schule ich habe eine AG die mache ich
seit 2009 und als danke schön dafür
bekomme ich von der Schule dieses
wirklich wundervolle Atelier gestellt in
Form einer Pyramide mitten auf dem
Schulgelände und ja hier kann ich mich
austoben seine großen Themen sind die
Natur und ziemlich abgefahrene
Experimente mit fließenden Farben die er
dann riesig vergrößert doch Anfang 2020
gab es einen riesigen Dämpfer 2020 mit
Beginn von Corona den lockdowns ging es
mir halt persönlich sehr schlecht auch
viele Ausstellungen sind alle gecancelt
worden für sponk ein absoluter Tiefpunkt
doch er erinnerte sich an ein altes
Projekt seit 2016 male ich jedes Jahr
live auf dem Summerjam Festival Köln
ganz großes und auf dem Festival äh habe
ich dann live gesprüht und dann kam der
Gedanke auf dass man doch das Bild was
ich sprühen dann auch versteigern kann
für einen guten Zweck und das haben wir
erstmal über die Plattform von
Summerjam selber über die Facebook Seite
gemacht und das war ein bisschen holprig
doch dann ist der auf United Charity
aufmerksam geworden eine Plattform die
nichts anderes anbietet als Dinge für
den guten Zweck zu versteigern und das
geht natürlich auch mit Gemälden also
ich habe Anfang 2020 habe ich den
Kontakt zu einer United Charity gefunden
und hatte dort dann die Möglichkeit über
Auktionen meine Kunst zur Verfügung zu
stellen um dann mit dem Erlös für
Naturschutzprojekte dann zu helfen
bisher habe ich an den WWF gespendet und
der WWF ist dann auch durch meinen
wirken Partner von United Charity
geworden und dort habe ich jetzt
bestimmt schon zehn bis 15 Werke von mir
dann versteigert für ihn eine Bestimmung
und extrem wichtig um überhaupt weiter
arbeiten zu können und ich habe dadurch
wieder Sinn auch in meiner Kunst
gefunden ich habe dadurch Hoffnung
geschöpft dass ich wirklich was gutes
tun kann und ich würde sagen das hat mir
wirklich sehr viel für meine für meine
für mein Wohlbefinden auch momentan dass
ich halt ja sage ich mal von der Natur
nicht nur nehme sondern auch geben kann
denn das ist besonders wichtig für ihn
weil die Natur mein
hauptinspirationsmittel ist habe ich
auch immer mehr den den Hang dafür
entwickelt dass ich die Natur die mir
diese Inspiration gibt dass ich diese
auch bewahren muss weil ich in der Welt
sehe wie viel in der Natur mittlerweile
zerstört wird und dass die Natur von
Menschen immer weiter weggedrängt wird
und so hat er jetzt noch mal eine
vollkommen neue Dimension erreicht
inzwischen Sprite er riesige Flächen und
das für einen ganz besonderen Zweck
Wichtigste ist dass ich in unseren
urbanen Bereichen in der Öffentlichkeit
durch meine Graffiti Kunst überhaupt
erstmal wieder auf Natur aufmerksam
mache
weil die meisten Menschen gerade hier im
Ruhrgebiet wirklich nur noch von Stadt
zu Stadt zu Stadt gehen und immer mehr
den Hang zu Natur verlieren und aus dem
Grund möchte ich halt wirklich genau
darauf aufmerksam machen wieder die
Liebe zur Natur wecken für ihn ist das
Bildungsarbeit im besten Sinne die
visuelle Bildung also nicht jetzt dass
die Leute in Text lesen sondern dass die
Leute halt wirklich auch im Rahmen der
Kunst ich abstrahiere ja auch ich stelle
ja nicht einfach ich nehme mir nicht
einfach nur ein Bild und mal das Bild
sondern die Leute sollen dann halt auch
wirklich noch Details finden sich mit
meinem Bild beschäftigen dass zum
Beispiel ein Bild ne ich sag mal
Graffiti Kunstwerk ist ja vielleicht
dann auch in der eigenen Wohngegend wo
man dann jeden Tag vorbei läuft und ich
möchte dass man in diesem Bild auch
immer wieder neue Details entdeckt damit
man sich mit meiner Kunst auch
auseinandersetzt und für dieses Video
hat er jetzt dieses Bild gesprengt und
ihr könnt es jetzt bekommen wenn ihr bei
der Versteigerung mitbietet von mir
werde ich jetzt im Anschluss bei United
Charity versteigert und den kompletten
erlöst an den WWF spenden
um unsere Welt ein bisschen besser zu
machen und hier geht es zur
Versteigerung draufklicken und wenn es
nur aus neu ist ich drücke allen die
Daumen bis dann bleibt